we opened the show yesterday with a
discussion about the crisis of
masculinity and the rise of Andrew Tate
and to very Briefly summarize the key
points made in that conversation boys
are growing up in a culture that is
openly hostile to masculinity and many
are forced to navigate the Minefield
without the benefits of strong male role
models to show them the path and this
crisis is self-perpetuating it grows
exponentially because the young men with
absentee fathers eventually become
absentee fathers themselves repeating
the cycle indefinitely unto infinity and
into this field of confusion and man
hatred steps guys like Andrew Tate and
others quickly earning an enormous
following of young men who
understandably flock to somebody who has
a message that Embraces masculinity
rather than treating it like a disease
Andrew Tate very often good at
identifying the problems in our culture
as they pertain to the situation at
Memphis and deserves credit for speaking
up in defense of masculinity rather than
denigrating it and calling for its
eradication essentially but in my view
he misses the mark when it comes to the
remedy he seems to basically understand
the disease but he doesn't have the
right prescription for it or at least
the full prescription
yes men should reject the programming
that our culture wants to subject them
to programming which seeks to neuter and
feminize them yes they should work hard
they should take care of their minds and
their bodies yes they should strive for
Success including financial success
but a life of Hedonism and materialism
and luxurious wealth remaining unmarried
while sleeping with dozens of different
women and so on
is not the ideal to strive towards
rather what men are called to and
created for and the only sort of life
that will be truly happy that they'll
find true happiness and joy in is a life
of service as protector and provider men
the vast majority of men anyway are
called to be husbands and fathers to be
leaders of their families
now they may be called to lead in other
ways too but first they must care for
their families if there's any saving
our civilization at this point
which I think there is
but if there is this is how we'll be
done and this is who will do it
it's not going to be saved by
influencers who are sitting in front of
cameras whether the guy in front of the
camera is Andrew Tate or me or anyone
else it'll be saved through the
formation and preservation of strong
intact loving and well-led Families
that is the only way it is the only way
forward
if every man in the country starts going
to the gym and starts making lots of
money and starts having sex with lots of
attractive women and yet they don't get
married and stay married and have
children and raise and love those
children
then we will still be headed to ruin
it'll be a slightly different kind of
Ruin but ruin all the same
those men themselves will ultimately
find the happiness that uh that they are
able to derive in that lifestyle they'll
find that it's shallow and it's fleeting
and in the end
they'll die alone loved by no one loving
no one
remembered by no one leaving no Legacy
behind
the feminized and neutered and
effeminate man that our left-wing
culture seeks to create and then this
other sort of man both unmarried both
childless
will look very similar in the end
having taken two very different paths
just to arrive together at essentially
the same place
it's the family man the devoted father
and husband whose different path
actually leads to a different and much
better conclusion
now I've of course been preaching this
message for as long as I've had an
audience to preach to and I have found
that
there are like two or three basic
responses or rebuttals I guess that I
always hear from young men who who may
for the most part line up with me
ideologically but who doubt the wisdom
of the get married and have kids
prescription
and I was greeted with these same
responses after the show yesterday and
many messages and comments what I'd like
to do today is answer
the objections or at least what seems to
be the one principal objection
the claim that I so often hear is that
well marriage and family life is a trap
it's a scam
especially for men the whole thing is
rigged against us
there is nothing for a man to do but
give up on the entire Enterprise and and
go his own way
in fact there's a whole movement online
men go their own way and that's
basically the idea
give up on this stuff and and do
something else
this argument was summarized in a
comment from a listener named Joshua
which I'll read because I think it just
is representative of this sort of
mentality he says still sounds like mad
in most tradcons definition of what
masculinity means is exclusively through
the lens of women and children's wants
and needs unfortunately that ideal will
no longer work in the modern world with
birth control hookup culture social
media and court systems that favor women
and the denigration of traditional
masculinity I don't agree with all of
Tate's views but it sure beats Matt's
prescriptions for young men
again I've read a great many comments
making the same kind of point a private
message from another listener has a
similar theme says Matt I agree with
many of your opinions but your message
to men is off base young men follow
Andrew Tate because his lifestyle is the
ideal whether you admit it or not wealth
Fame status beautiful women were
biologically programmed to want those
things marriage is a losing game The
Only Solution in modern society is to
reject the life of service as you call
it
so what is the problem with uh this view
well to begin with
it's nothing less than a full
unconditional surrender to the culture
it's true that the culture has
increasingly made it difficult for both
men and women to form and maintain
strong intact lasting families and
that's because the elites who run our
society don't want you to live that kind
of life
they prefer that you focus on your
individual wants
unfulfilling your own needs and
satisfying your own desires that's what
they prefer for you that's the life they
want for you A self-focused life is
precisely the sort of Life they wish for
you
makes you easier to manipulate less of a
threat to their agenda
not really a threat at all I mean if
you're just out there focused on
yourself
um you know being a consumer buying lots
of things for yourself consuming things
for yourself
um you know and all the rest of it
you're not a threat to to their agenda
at all I mean you're going along with it
um all of the things mentioned by Joshua
and his comment
all of those things represent a
conspiracy against the families right
about that
the way the family court systems are set
up birth control all the rest of it
it's an attack on the Family
so what is the answer
to give up
to give the conspirators exactly what
they want to reward them for their
efforts by turning your back on the very
thing they've been assaulting for
decades
the family is the Fortress that they
have been attacking
and you can defend it with your life or
you can wave the white flag
but if you choose to surrender then at
least be honest about what you're doing
be honest this is not a rejection of the
left's agenda of a cultural Elites
agenda you are you are submitting to it
it is a submission
it is certainly not the strong or
masculine response to run away and
abandon your post
to stop fighting because the fight is
too difficult
I mean that approaches many things but
it certainly isn't manly
and where do you go instead I mean what
is the next move
to give up on the families to give up on
human civilization
seeing as how there cannot be a human
civilization without the family so
uh what's Plan B after you've given up
on civilization where what's next
you're also giving up on yourself on
your own legacy your own bloodline your
you are descended from a long line of
men stretching back thousands of years
who formed families and raised children
offer often under circumstances far more
dire than what we face
and you're giving up on them too
you you are surrendering your future and
your past you're giving up on everything
and what is your consolation prize
finding financial success
I mean the unfortunate irony is that
many of the people that many of The Men
Who uh give up on these things in in
favor of well I'll just focus on myself
and try to be financially successful
many of them are never even going to be
Financial financially successful so they
end up with just nothing they end up
broke and alone with nothing
but even if you find it
the financial success
so what I mean who cares about money if
you have nothing meaningful to spend it
on
I have money I I don't have Andrew
Tate's money but I have money
then nearly all the joy and happiness I
derived from having money is that it
allows me to provide for my family
that's pretty much it that's the entire
thing that's why I like having the money
is that I find great pleasure in being
able to care for a wife and six kids
proud of that fact
if I didn't have them the money would
mean very little to me I mean I could
buy nice things and drive a fancy car
and live in my nice house alone
but for what
now does that mean that if you start a
family that you're guaranteed to live a
joyful and fulfilled life well of course
not it's a risk
and yes the risks are in some ways much
greater in modern times we have all been
poisoned by this demonic culture to one
extent or another we are all poisoned
if you marry someone you are marrying
someone who has been poisoned who has
ingested the poison
who has uh you know had taken a drink
from The Well of modern culture
everybody has as have you and yes if
things go sideways
if you're a man you marry a woman and
your wife turns out to be a disloyal
vulture
or if you turn out to be a disloyal
vulture or you both do
um the deck will be stacked against you
in court no no there's no question about
that
divorce May ruin your life
and you know if you give your heart to
someone if you bind yourself to them not
only through the marriage vow but then
also through children you conceive
together
then you will have they will have all
they need
to rip your guts out and burn your life
to the ground that is absolutely true
that's the risk okay but it's a risk
worth taking
every great joy can become a great
tragedy if you aren't careful
or if you have very bad luck
that's true
so is the answer then to forgo all joy
to say forget about Joy because it might
not work out
to embrace a life of loneliness and
misery because you're worried that if
you aim higher you'll end up
lonely and miserable
you're worried that in the end you'll
end up in this state so instead you say
well I might as well just live in this
state to begin with
doesn't make any sense
so you take the risk
and you mitigate the risk at the same
time by being smart about who you marry
and by grounding your marriage and and
your family in faith and mutual devotion
and by working hard every day to hold up
your own end of the bargain
because yeah there are some men out
there who do everything right and
they're and and and you know they're
great men and they're devoted to their
families
and they're intensely loyal and all of
that and their families fall apart
anyway because they accidentally married
a soulless disloyal scumbag I mean that
does happen and sometimes it happens in
the reverse
but that's not
that's not the majority of cases
most of the time it takes two to tango
two to get married two to ruin the
marriage
which means that marriage is not a mere
role of the dice
there's quite a lot you can do to secure
your good fortune
that's why I never cared about the
statistics you know what I get was
getting married and I heard about this
statistically this is I'm not a
statistic
I'm not just some number on a
spreadsheet
and neither is my wife we're human
beings
I I'm not subject to statistics
not merely subject to them
because the one thing statistics don't
take into account are choices
it's about the choices you make
whether your marriage works or not it's
about choices that are made in the
marriage
if one or both of you make bad choices
your your chances are going to be very
poor if you make good choices they won't
be that's what it is
and yet the risk is always there so will
you live in fear of it
or will you have the courage
and go forward anyway
one other thing I want to say you know I
I and this is important to say that
it's just not true okay it's just not
true that a life of obscene luxury and
materialism and selfishness and
self-service and of you know sleeping
with many different women and and all of
that it's not true that that is the
ideal
which we so often hear these days that's
the ideal
you know non-monogamy having many sexual
partners that's the ideal they say
that's not true
much less is it is it what we are
biologically programmed to desire
no it's what we're culturally programmed
to desire that is the cultural
programming
but I know that it's not biological
because I'm a biological organism and I
don't desire that
I don't want any life but the one I have
I don't want any woman but the one I
married
I mean you could listen to that and say
oh that's not true he's just saying
that's a cope on your part
that's resentment Envy talking
if I could do my life over from the
start I would find my wife again and
marry her again if I lived 100 lives I'd
marry her in all of them
that's what it means to love somebody
and love is the ideal
because it's Not Mere biological
programming it is transcendent
and trust me it's well worth the risk
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]